[Music]
all right so have you this guy has been
popping up in my timeline a lot and I
was really trying to find people that
were trying to defend
um that we're trying to defend uh
fetterman right
so you've seen this guy I'm sure he's
come up uh Brian Tyler Cohen
this guy yeah oh yeah 1.5 million Subs
he's another one of those that's
completely 100 DNC fakely astro turf guy
Dude where's this guy come from right so
uh that is that's why the title of
today's episode by the way is Brian dead
and yes I listened to their ideas and I
want to talk about them when John
fetterman brings up houses the irony is
he didn't pay for his own house he got
there it's Grace it's fun
threat to the United States persist okay
here we go here we go like a number of
these
uh 50 grams Nationwide abortion ban it's
because he was coming up with a [ __ ]
enough [ __ ] answer in terms of what
he would do when that when he was
actually presented with that issue all
these Republicans say the same thing
once they have power they'll do
something completely different if you
want to codify Roe if you are of the
mind that women should have bodily
autonomy that they should have control
over their own bodies if they should
watch this guy controller of their own
1.5 million Subs this episode alone
foreign
I feel like I'm watching a promo on like
dark AstroTurf and he sounds like a
child he sounds like a 15 year old I
don't understand reproductive Health
then there is only one party who has
vowed to do exactly so his so just what
he's saying is by the way and this thing
is like look ignore the fact that
fetterman's mentally [ __ ] okay
ignore the fact that he cannot even
probably [ __ ] by himself if you want
abortions and again whenever you see
guys like this like like this Brian
Tyler Coleman guy whenever you see guys
like this
they are 100 of the time like the same
one like good news guy wow big news guys
and then the guy accused of raping
somebody that all those or Brooklyn dad
which I know that's Marsha's favorite
Brooklyn Dad when you see all these guys
I hate them so much let's get the worst
he's so obnoxious we all have the one
that we hate the most but but you know
what I mean or Joe from jurors whenever
whatever they're saying whenever they're
saying is 100 the DNC talking point
printed on a piece of paper that they're
going to read and like we've been saying
his defense for the whole thing right
now the entire [ __ ] thing you saw
was
the entire thing you saw was abortions
and that's it that who's vowed to codify
Roe which was the law of the land for 50
years by the way I'm sorry I don't mean
to keep pausing but what a [ __ ] soy
boy like I don't want to bring I know
that word is overused everything he's
you're right he's like a teenager he's
like he's like a I don't like a wife you
know it's amazing you grow a beard
50 years women had the right to a safe
and legal abortion in the United States
this sounds like somebody that will be
helping me at Best Buy pick a TV not
having 1.5 million subscribers
there's one party right now who will
continue to preserve those uh those
those same look at them look down at the
talking points privacy rights and by the
way it's not just he does it a lot after
he does it a lot he thinks he thinks
it's not whenever whenever you see this
okay abortion we're looking at
a Republican party that's hostile to
same-sex marriage we're looking at a
Republican party seriously how old is
this guy this voice is bugging me uh can
you look look at my child look him up
Brian Tyler Cohen look him up uh uh let
me know Virgie or Frozen one of you two
we're looking at a Republican party
that's hostile to uh contraception so if
you're someone out there who thinks that
you have the right hey man I hear that
but look you're just my weed dealer I
know you want me to stay in here for a
bit but you got to shut up you gotta
shut up I know you're really into
politics but give me the weed look if
you want we'll play some video games I
understand you don't want cars going in
and out but you got to shut up yeah
seriously you got it under Street
Fighter with you if you just shut up but
you gotta stop
this is like being cornered by a super
lip like it's the worst right to birth
control birth control
conservative liberal independent doesn't
matter if you think that you have the
right to birth control in this country
in 2022 there is one party that is
vowing to support those rights
nobody's stopping birth control
this is hysterical you're being
hysterical
there's one party that's protecting your
right to contraception to say no with
this guy I'm having trouble even picking
apart his political argument because I
want to bully him
mm-hmm because he's a [ __ ] nerd and
it's like you pointed the voice out I
can't unhear it dude I just can't
respect you you have that voice
did anyone find this age out
no I looked it's not in his early 30s is
all I can get oh wait a second so you're
telling me hold on hold on hold on hold
on see this is the stuff you're telling
me somebody with
1.5
million YouTube subscribers okay
doesn't have there's YouTube wikis on
people that have a to have like ten
thousand and we don't know this guy's
[ __ ] age
no no no no no that can't there's no way
uh he is also an actor for and a
producer for famous movies like well you
know it's coming of course
and Independence Day
what was he in Independence Day
I don't know
probably what child
he I'm really trying to find
any info and it's super weird that we
don't know this guy's age this should be
easy this should be the no wait a second
I'm sorry again you want to tell me this
is an astro turf okay sure what did you
find his IMDb page yeah yeah
you're you're telling me that Brian
Tyler Cohen
again 1.5 million subscribers doesn't
even have a Wikipedia like when you
Google this guy and I'm not even kidding
you after you get through his socials
with through his like you know his
YouTube and his and his Twitter and all
that it's like he doesn't exist
I'm being serious do it yourself
go home if you're when you get home and
Google Brian Tyler Cohen I promise you
after you get past the normal stuff
it's like he never existed yeah it's
this is weird this is weird right
um
this guy was born in America to his
American parents however Tyler Brian
Tyler's exact date of birth is under
wraps nevertheless
currently in his 30s both his parents
are health care workers and working
relentlessly during the covet pandemic
no no no no no no no no why would his oh
I'm sure why would why would this guy's
age be under wraps
that's it's it's why it seems odd you
can't be on the internet without them
knowing your mother's address and this
guy
you no one no one's even bothered by the
way how can how do you have 1.5 million
people and immersed nobody I've heard of
you that's my point for the most part
knows the any of course I know that guy
this guy doesn't pop up anywhere this
guy doesn't show up anywhere except
astro turf like when you Google the John
Federman debate he's one of the First
videos and of course I don't subscribe
to him this guy I don't give a [ __ ]
about his Lefty talking points here you
go 1.5 million subscribers let's compare
things this is a patreon show so it's
perfect
we have 40 what 43 44 000 subscribers on
YouTube right
and we have about 16 1700 patrons give
or take okay
he has 1.5 million 1.5
million
subscribers uh on YouTube and he has 456
000 views just on this video okay
um he has guesses patrons how many do
you think he has five dollar levels what
he has just like ours same thing so you
get out of a couple thousand patrons by
now okay 400.
and that's how you could tell when stuff
is astro turf because you could ask
yourself YouTube your YouTube views you
could even AstroTurf comments but
patrons having people actually sign up
and pay for something you can't bot a p
you cannot bot patreon because then they
could sue the [ __ ] out of you if you did
you know what I mean like that's a like
that but everything else YouTube will
work with these people they don't give a
[ __ ]
that's true I mean and I bet you he
doesn't have the money or the amount he
makes uh visible right
no sir but I bet it's an astronomical
amount of money I bet he has 400 people
and they're all giving him like a
thousand dollars a month because they're
probably like
DNC [ __ ] prop up accounts
uh Brian likes to maintain secrecy about
himself Cohen has not received revealed
his exact date of birth that's all I'm
getting again
want to put money why
I mean my guess he's not in his 30s
This Guy's in his early 20s mid-20s
maybe when is the first time he appears
on the internet see that's the thing
five years ago five years ago five years
ago but he does have IMDb credits going
back hang on I'm sorry guys I just heard
a noise
didgeridoo
um
what are we saying virgin his his IMDb
credits go back to 2012.
I kind of I kind of now I'm gonna become
obsessed with this right
I mean he was known as an actor right
I'm I am now obsessed with this astro
turf
piece of [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] this guy is 100
DNC 100 DNC groomed and remember like we
found out many many times when it comes
to all these people right-wing and
neocons too they all start as actors
let's say all start as actors what
happened
my bird feeder fell oh anyway they all
start as actors all of them and this
guy's another actor they probably go oh
whatever this guy will be perfect for
the cause and they got him and then they
AstroTurf him and they promised them set
amount of views send them out of this or
that I'm sorry but I'm not buying this
I'm gonna play a little bit more here
but while I do that I'm going to pull up
this [ __ ] socialblade
same-sex marriage to to abortion rights
only one party and it's not Dr Oz's
party
also one other one other point uh you
saw him look down do you see him again
and read again he's not yeah without his
notes he's got nothing yeah because he's
he's actually a stupid person
uh by the way I posted what was the
closest thing to his Wiki to a Wikipedia
page on in the Show links
blow up this is ridiculous
because he was just dead dead dead dead
dead then boom
he is doing something they're doing
something dude in terms of oh they would
you social blade him yeah there's
something's going on questioning
legitimacy of the 2020 election
um Oz had come out previously despite
what he said in this in this previous
debate Oz has come out previously and
refused to validate the legitimacy of
the 2020 election uh he said that uh he
tweeted uh about uh not tweeted he said
of the 2020 election quote I've
discussed it with President Trump and we
cannot move on
he's also said quote we cannot leave
2020 behind good I don't even like uh
that's the problem your talking points
of you guys have been saying the same
thing over and over and over and over
again and nobody
[ __ ] cares because until you fix
inflation and the moment you run out of
the moment you guys [ __ ] the moment
you guys run out of [ __ ] baby formula
you [ __ ] yourself
like that's it
I'm so like I know I'm an Amber too I'm
I'm really sucked in now because I'm
looking at what you said and
yeah
this is spoopy let's see YouTube channel
um weekly total subscribers weekly
wait hey buddy wait a second this this
is bro I'm sorry but this is not right
what is going I'm not saying he doesn't
have legitimate viewers because
obviously he does he probably has 436 of
them
because that's how many patrons he has
shouldn't I said I don't believe there
was an Insurrection I believe it was
individuals coming from different places
yes different places incited by Donald
Trump yes but that doesn't make
fetterman not [ __ ]
guy who's lying about his age which
again is weird why are you lying about
that it's very that dude dude I'm this
is [ __ ] weird bro
oh my God
and sacked the capital to assassinate a
bunch of elected officials including
Mike Pence
um so I mean this again nobody was ever
going in to try to assassinate people
again that was never happening it's
funny when you hear their talking points
it's just they literally read points off
they never go into any detail because
they can't because they're [ __ ]
you know well because it's hard to go
into detail when you're lying
yeah good point
somebody who will Who will twist himself
into pretzels to conform with whatever
the Republican party line is of the day
and so he's obviously too afraid uh to
incur the wrath of Donald Trump so if he
has to toe the party line when it comes
to Trump when it comes to the January 6
Insurrection how can you be on the
internet be an actor and have 1.5
million subs and how do you successfully
hide your age I just I'm sorry I've been
on the I don't mean it's stuck it's
stuck on this but I've been on the
internet too long and I've never seen
this happen
uh check Show links Royce okay
uh tell me that doesn't seem very
manufactured the the partner one you
mean
yes okay hold on let's see what this is
um Brian Tyler likes to keep his
personal life to himself however he has
revealed that he has a girlfriend
through a post on Instagram Brian wished
a Happy Valentine's Day his beloved
woman Ashley Brinkman
uh just like Tyler Ashley has also tried
her hands in acting
it's another actor
she has appeared in movies like blue
call and the Malibu tape so most
importantly as she's a reporter on
camera personality and social media
manager currently she works at Hollywire
Brian and Ashley prefer to keep their
love life away from media as a result
they have not revealed when they started
dating or how long they've been dating
regardless the couples often post their
intimate photos and social media
confirmed okay this is fake this all
fake hey Brian you're fake you're faking
you're a faker and you know you are
your manufactured piece of [ __ ] now if
I'm not sue me but then sue me it's got
to be somebody's nephew or you know what
I mean see somebody's hey Brian soon but
sue me Brian because you don't want to
be sued that way in Discovery I'll find
out your [ __ ] age
Hey so uh does anybody else find it
weird that his uh made up [ __ ]
girlfriend starred in blue call in
another movie Malibu tape that was
directed by a man named Brian farmer
that has no picture and no information
of them on IMDb and also Brian is the
star of their next two upcoming films
no it's not weird why would that be
weird
why not I think his name's Brian forward
I'm sorry man but this but this this
this guy this guy is there this is 100
manufactured made in a [ __ ] lab
specifically for this kind of [ __ ]
just completely propped up and bought it
one hundred percent you're a [ __ ]
phony
does he do live streams
doubtful
let me go to his channel Brian Tyler
Cohen videos
sort by
that's most recent
I'm not seeing any stream no he did he
did he streamed 20 hours ago
but he turns
[Music]
does he that way you can't really see
the activity in there when he was like I
would love to see the activity uh-huh
we'd have to find this guy alive so we
could see the activities
this guy is 100 fake
in every aspect
one point and not you you don't know
that you you again I gotta tell me your
[ __ ] age go [ __ ] yourself